( intro music )
Man 1:
Come explore with us!
Man 2: I am like
trembling right now!
Voiceover: I have the
coolest job in the world.
Now we're building
things to understand more
about the world around us.
Woman 1: I love this!
Man 3: That was insane.
( cry of joy )
Voiceover: We found eight
new species of fish.
Man 4: Look.
Man 5: This is what we lost.
Woman 2: It turns out
people really don't believe
we can do this.
Voiceover: That's awesome,
that's why I do what I do.
( applause )
Boyd: And why don't we begin
with our Explorer-in-Residence.
We'll begin with Enric.
Enric: Great!
I'm going to tell you
a little story now.
When I was a kid growing up on
the Mediterranean coast of Spain
I was completely
fascinated by the documentaries
that Jacques Cousteau
showed us on TV.
Now, that was in the 70s
and he showed us
these amazing coral reefs
lots of sharks, whales,
sea lions, it was so fantastic.
But when I was
swimming in the ocean,
when I was diving, when
I was later the professor
at the University of California,
this what I saw.
Those coral reefs that
he showed us were gone.
Places that I loved were less
and less alive over time.
So I was studying human
impacts in the ocean.
And I saw those dead
reefs covered by algae
and slime and the big fishes
were gone.
These fish that you can see
are smaller
than my diving masks.
I quit my job as a professor
and I just started going
to these remote places.
And I started this project
that we call Pristine Seas.
The goal of this project
is to go to the most remote,
uninhabited, untouched places
in the ocean,
the wildest places in the ocean.
A coral reef that
looks like this,
where the corals are alive
and predators dominate.
And we combine exploration,
scientific research,
compelling media
and then we inspire
the leaders of the countries
that own these places
to protect them in
very large reserves.
In the last five years,
we've been to nine places.
And we got five protected.
Covering a total of almost half
a million square kilometers.
And in the next few years
we are going to
a few more of these
places to try to protect
the last places that
still look like the ocean
that was thousands of years ago.
Thank you.
( applause )
Boyd: Now Tristram Stuart
is gonna give us a little
overview of his work quickly.
Tristram: We're chopping
down rainforest
to grow more food
but at the same time,
a billion people are hungry.
And yet we're wasting one third
of the world's food supply.
That is something of a tragedy
but I've made it
my life's mission
to show that this is
a colossal opportunity.
If we need to cut down
our environmental impact
and increase food availability
where it's needed most,
cutting food waste
is a really good place to start.
These green beans show
you just how simple
some of the solutions
to food waste can be.
I draw your attention
to the word trimmed.
These beans have been
trimmed to size
to fit into these
plastic containers.
That means that Kenyan farmers
growing these beans for export
to European markets, are cutting
sometimes 30, 40 percent
of the beans they've grown
in a country were the land
and the water
that they're using
to grow these beans
are scarce resources.
20 tons a day of waste
coming out of
this single depot,
just outside Nairobi,
and contractors collecting
this waste
have to sign a contract saying
they won't feed
any of this good food
to hungry people.
It will all be treated as waste.
We're paying for that
crime in our supply chains.
What we did is four things.
First of all,
raise awareness
through public campaigns
on ugly fruit and vegetables
and why these standards
are unnecessary.
Number two, pass a law
within the United Kingdom
saying that when
supermarkets cause their
suppliers to waste food,
they should share
the cost of it.
Number three, help
farmers in those countries
develop secondary markets
to get some of that food
to markets.
And number four, work
with the supermarkets
to change those standards.
We got Tescos to
change the way they ask
for the beans to be trimmed.
They now trim only on
one side of the bean
rather than two,
it's not far enough.
They've gone half way
but Kenyan farmers...
( laughter )
...are producing five
percent more bean
per unit of production
than they were before.
We did that in a few months.
Similar story with
bananas in Ecuador.
That's the waste of
one banana plantation
after one day of harvest.
Bananas in Costa Rica.
These are carrots
being wasted
because they are too long
to fit into these
supermarket plastic crates.
It's crazy and it's
happening everywhere.
We have led a global revolution
against food waste
by doing positive campaigning
and feeding the five thousand,
which is the name
of our organization,
at an event that we used
to launch our campaigns
where we feed five thousand
people, all on food
that would otherwise be wasted,
"Filling bellies, not bins".
We also set up the
Gleaning Network in Britain
and now across Europe
were we take volunteers
to fields to harvest
some of this unused crop
and get it people
who are hungry
and also communicate
about those basic,
original sources of food waste
and what we can do about it.
My next mission is
to come to America.
I'm here now and
I'm making friends.
( applause )
And I will show you
why it's most important.
What this shows is
that America has
twice as much food
in its shops and restaurants
than is actually required
to keep the population alive.
That is a huge
opportunity to save money,
save resources, save
impact on the environment.
We're gonna start
with portion sizes
and we're gonna move
up to the farms.
We're gonna cause
a food waste revolution
here in America,
we're coming soon.
Thank you very much.
( applause )
Boyd: Excellent.
And now Shivani Bhalla from our
Big Cats initiative in Kenya.
Shivani: In under a century
we have lost
over 90 percent of
our planet's lions.
Where I'm from in Kenya
the situation
is just as serious.
We have only two thousand
lions left in our country.
We work to try and understand
why this is happening.
Lions are running out of space.
They also come in to
contact with people.
The local people,
whose livelihoods
depend on their livestock,
are often targeted by lions.
In Samburu, in northern
Kenya where I live,
our population has
grown from 11 lions
to over 50 now as a result
of conservation efforts.
I work with a team
and our mission is
to promote the co-existence
between lions and people
in northern Kenya.
We do this through a number
of community programs.
One of which is
our warrior program
known as Warrior Watch.
Here in this picture
you see three of the warriors
I work with.
Previously neglected when
it came to conservation,
these warriors are now
wildlife ambassadors.
They're engaged in conservation.
We have 16 warriors now
working in the region.
When we started the program,
we asked the warriors
what would you like
in exchange for all
this great wildlife information
that you give us?
And they said,
we would like education.
We have never been to school.
These are young men
aged between 15 to 25,
who've never had that
opportunity to go
and learn how to read and write.
We've now changed this.
And over the last five years
all 17 of our warriors
can read and write,
both in English and the
national language, Kiswahili.
This picture was taken
a couple of weeks ago
at our annual lion kids camp.
They've never seen a lion.
They've only heard negative
experiences with lions.
They'd seen
the remains of a camel
after a lion
had preyed on them.
But we changed that,
we took these kids
to see their first ever lion.
And their faces say it all.
As they saw their first lion
they whispered to me,
Simba Simba.
( laughter )
And this is what gives
me hope for the future.
Thank you.
( applause )
Boyd: And now Jack
Andraka, our inventor.
Jack: So I suppose
my story really began
when I was 13,
when a close family friend,
who was like an uncle to me,
actually passed away
from pancreatic cancer.
And when the disease
hit so close to home,
I knew I needed to learn more.
So I went online to find answers
and what I had found
really shocked me.
You see 85 percent of
all pancreatic cancers
are diagnosed late,
when someone has
less than a two percent
chance of survival.
And as I looked deeper,
I found an even
more shocking statistic.
You see there is
currently no standard way
for detecting pancreatic cancer.
Our conventional method
is the 60 year old technique.
I mean first off that's
older than my dad...
( laughter )
...but also it costs
$800 per test
and it's grossly inaccurate,
missing 30 percent
of all cancers
and thus is rarely ever used
for screening
of pancreatic cancer.
So armed with eighth
grade biology,
I decided to set out
to change the field
of cancer diagnostics.
( laughter )
Bit lofty of a goal
but I was going to do it.
And so essentially
what I did is
I stumbled across
how we are currently diagnosing
these cancers and what
we're doing is
we're looking
at your blood stream
particularly for these
variations in protein levels
and while it sounds
extremely straightforward,
it's anything but because you
have liters and liters of blood
which is about an innumerable
numbers of these proteins.
So it's like trying to
find a needle in a stack
of nearly identical needles.
However, undeterred due
to my teenage optimism
or how some people label it,
complete and utter ignorance
of the entire field,
I continued on
and I essentially found
a database of 8000 proteins
that are found in
your bloodstream
when you have these cancers.
Essentially I found
this one protein
that I could use
called mesothelin
and it's just your ordinary
run of the mill type protein,
unless of course you have
pancreatic, ovarian
or lung cancer.
In which case it's found
in these very high levels
in your blood stream.
But also the key is,
is that it's found
in earlier stages
of the disease.
When someone has close to
100 percent chance of survival
and essentially what
I did is I combined
something called
carbon nanotubes,
essentially the
superheros of material,
these long thin tubes
of carbon.
They have these
amazing properties.
And all you do is
it's like making
chocolate chip cookies.
You put them in this
giant thing of water.
You pour in some nanotubes,
add some antibodies,
which are molecules
that only react with one cancer
biomarker, mix it up,
take some paper,
dip it, dry it
and you can detect cancer.
And then I sent out
my procedure
to 200 labs at Johns
Hopkins University,
got a 199 "No's".
Seven months later after
getting accepted into a lab,
I stumble out with
one small paper sensor
that cost three cents
and takes five minutes to run,
making it 168 times faster,
over 26,000 times less expensive
and over 400 times
more sensitive
than our conventional
methods of detection.
But also so far
it can detect the cancer
in the earliest stage
when someone has
close to 100 percent
chance of survival
and so far has over
90 percent accuracy.
It can be broadly applied
to pretty much any disease,
ranging from Alzheimer's,
other forms of cancer,
even HIV,
AIDS and heart disease.
So that's my research.
( applause )
Boyd: So Enric one
thing you have found which,
this is a really great news,
is if you can set aside
a marine area
and keep... and just
make it a reserve
for a brief period of
time and we've been
able to do that, you
were talking about some
of the successes in your talk,
because it was once
a desert doesn't
mean it will always
stay a desert.
It comes back.
Enric: Exactly, the ocean
and nature has this
incredible capacity to rebound.
This photograph was taken
on the Medes Islands
Marine Reserve,
on the Costa Brava
in northern Spain.
And this guy
is Pierre-Yves Cousteau,
Jacques Cousteau's
youngest son.
And next to him is a 25
kilo grouper, la cernia ,
which are gone from most
of the Mediterranean,
except in Marine reserves.
Think about most of the ocean
like a debit account
where everybody withdraws
and nobody makes a deposit.
You don't need to
be an economist
to know what's going to happen.
But this reserve where
there is no fishing
is like a savings account where
principal set aside
that produces interest.
So the abundance of fish,
there are tons of fish
per square mile in the reserves,
increases 450 percent
in less than 10 years.
Boyd: And how hard is it to
people to set aside an area,
to say if you only stop fishing
for 10 years,
you'll be so amply rewarded?
Enric: The benefits to
fishing are happen earlier.
In some places in actually
the last three years
after creation of the reserves
there are so many fish
inside the reserve,
they reproduce so much, that
some of these fish spill over
the boundaries of these reserves
so the fishermen
are catching more outside,
that's the interest.
Boyd: Tristram, let's just
put it out on the line.
You're a dumpster diver.
( laughter )
You go around and you
spy on people's trash.
But what have you found?
Is that where you first got
the clue how much
was being thrown out of
restaurants and grocery stores?
Tristram: Yeah, it is.
Actually I was 15 also
when my mission started.
I was collecting food waste for
my pigs from my school canteen,
the local baker,
and the green grocer
but I realized that
most of the food
I was giving to my pigs
was actually perfectly good
for human consumption.
And I remember the day,
I sat down for breakfast
with my pigs
and ate one of this perfectly
good loaves of bread
that the baker
had chucked away
and that was the first act
of what you could call
dumpster diving or freeganism.
This photograph,
you see, I moved to London
a few years ago,
and I stopped
being able to keep pigs.
So I decided to launch campaign
on feeding food waste to pigs,
which is the next best
thing after you've exhausted
all possibilities for
feeding it to humans.
Processed pig food
which has been grown
by deforesting the Amazon
to grow soy.
Europe imports
40 million tons every year.
This is the worst
thing that is going on
on the planet at the moment.
We're chopping down
forest to grow more food
and we can cancel out
a lot of demand for that
by changing the way,
first of all we eat
and waste food,
and secondly the way
we produce meat
by using waste products
rather than using virgin crops.
Boyd: Shivani, all of
us have had neighbors
we didn't exactly
get along with.
In this case for the Samburu,
the lions are their neighbors.
If you wanna make peace,
you invite them over for dinner.
So how do you make friends
if your neighbors are lions?
What do you do to make that
relationship harmonious?
Shivani: The big problem
in this area is conflict.
So when lions come along and
they attack people's livestock,
this is when
people don't like lions.
They don't want
lions in their area.
So we work with the
communities to reduce conflict.
We try to encourage them
to look after livestock better.
One of the big issues
is livestock
is always often lost.
So lions come across
sleeping camels at night
far from the village
and they will attack them.
So we encourage them look
after your livestock better.
Don't send young children
out to look after your livestock
because of course a little boy
is scared of lions,
yet warriors
are not scared of lions.
Also a night livestock
are kept in
what are known as bomas ,
livestock enclosures.
We work with them
to reinforce their bomas .
So at least they can
be more predator-proof.
Predators can't get in easily
and livestock can't get out.
So there are lots
of ways we can work
with the local
people to reduce
conflict from happening
in the first place.
And then they're much more
willing to live with lions.
Boyd: Good fences do
make good neighbors
in this case.
Shivani: Good fences
do make good neighbors.
Boyd: Now Jack, you
came up with this idea.
How do know that it works?
Are you in testing?
Did the head of the lab--
How did he react when you said,
look what I found
and how long were you there,
just over your summer vacation?
Jack: No for seven months.
Boyd: So he's been working there
his entire career.
Jack: Yes
Boyd: You come in
seven months later
and what does he say?
Jack: I mean to even
like get anything
was like really exciting for
him, he was in disbelief.
But essentially what
really tipped us off
that was working,
is its sensitivity. You see,
it could detect down to
like femtogram levels
which was really incredible
for these types of sensors,
especially given its cost
and how rapid it was.
And so we, once we saw
that then we started
working with mouse
blood samples
and we saw that was
effective there
so we instantly submitted
a patent and we're right now
in talks with several different
bio-tech companies
about getting it on the market
as soon as possible
just because I, unfortunately
can't run clinical trials.
As a high school student
I have SATs and
prom to worry about.
( laughter )
Now when we go
to the Pristine Seas,
we talk a lot about things
that we put in the ocean.
One thing
that we put in the ocean
are oil platforms.
Turns out
they actually create
artificial reefs
so this is actually a
life source,
these platforms.
What have you discovered there?
Is it spreading
beyond the platforms?
When we think of the oil wells,
we think of
the possibility of spills
but why are they
so popular for fish?
Enric: So we did a Pristine
Seas expedition to Gabon.
And the coast of
Gabon is mostly sandy.
And there are dozens
of oil platforms.
And these platforms
are the only hard substrate
in hundreds of kilometers
of coast.
We were told by the people
at the oil companies
about the safety.
It was like we're going to dive
into the Chernobyl
reactor or something.
( laughter )
It was-- They painted
such a dire picture
and we jumped in the water
and we could not believe it.
There were so many fish!
Rainbow runners like
these ones, tuna, sharks.
In the first 20 meters,
the first 60 feet of
these platforms,
there is more than one ton,
a thousand kilos of fish.
Boyd: Is that because coral
grows on the hard surface
that it wouldn't
have on the sandy bottom?
The hard surface
of the oil well.
Enric: Exactly, all the
animals that live on reefs
produce eggs and they
turn into larvae that float.
And if they don't find
a hard substrate to settle,
they die.
So now there is
this plan to work--
The government of Gabon is
working with the oil companies,
so the oil companies
will enforce
the area around
the oil companies
so there will be no fishing
and there's going to be
a haven for replenishing
the rest of the coast of Gabon.
Boyd: Who would
have thought
we're holding a beauty contest
for our fruits and vegetables?
Can you stop the
beauty contest?
Does that begin with
the market or the consumer?
Tristram: That's what the basis
of our campaigns are all about.
It's about instigating
popular revolt.
Literally it is revolting--
against food waste.
This is why
the big supermarkets
and why governments
are now listening to us.
Not because we're right
but because we have
a popular movement behind us.
And it's gonna sound funny
but ugly fruit and vegetables
since the launch of
our campaign
have become the fastest
growing sector
of the fresh produce market
in the United Kingdom.
Boyd: Do they offer it
at a different price?
Tristram: Different
prices in some places
or you just tell the story.
If you're a high end
demographic super market
or farmer's market,
you just say
well the skin on these apples
are blemished because
it hailed during the autumn.
And people like to hear
that kind of story
and will respond to that.
( laughter )
I mean, we're doing
the same thing with fish also.
Fish are being
chucked overboard
that are perfectly good
for consumption
by a process
called high grading.
Basically only bring in
the best specimens ashore.
Because you got a finite hold
and fishermen are
chucking them away.
In Europe that's being
exacerbated by quota systems
that make people chuck
over quota fish aboard.
And we're just changing
the legislation in Europe now
to make discarding
valuable fish at sea--
40 to 60 percent of fish
caught in European waters
is being chucked overboard.
Boyd: Now if you're going
to get the local people involved
in taking on the conservation
as being important to them,
they have to see some benefit
beyond just the fact
that they're lions.
One you have to show
them that tourist
are not going to show up
if they don't have elephants
and lions, if they're
all poached out.
'Cause that's what
they're coming to see.
So there's that dollar bit.
But do those dollars
from the tourist
in any way get to them
so that they
see a direct benefit.
Shivani: Absolutely. So tourist
that come to visit Samburu,
there's a huge percentage
that goes directly
back to the community.
The community then
use these funds
for health projects,
for school bursaries,
for water projects,
because water is
a big issue in our area.
We're in a semiarid desert,
there is no water.
You literally have
to dig for water
in the dry river beds.
So through the funds
that they get from tourism
they're able to do such things
and have more access to water.
Education is key.
Sending their children to school
is a big thing for them.
Now they are able to do that
through the benefits
they get from tourism.
Boyd: And they make
that connection
between the lions programs
you're doing the Ewaso...
Shivani: They do.
Boyd: and the education they're
getting is because of the lions?
Shivani: Absolutely, yeah.
So we've got
a great relationship
with the tourism,
managements and lodges
within our area.
We work closely
together so people
can really understand
the relationship between
tourist and conservation and
working with communities.
And they have seen that.
Boyd: And you've got
the Samburu Warriors
who are walking around
to see
where the lions are,
warning the people,
if it's getting close
to their cattle,
but they're such great trackers.
Do they also look for
human tracks of poachers?
Do you have 'em
on the watch for that?
Shivani: They do, our warriors
are basically out there
looking out for anything
so not just predators
but people as well.
Poaching is a big problem
in our area, northern Kenya.
So our warriors do
notify the wardens,
the rangers if they
see any kind of tracks
that look a little
bit suspicious.
They're very good
at aging the tracks.
They know exactly
when that track
has been through that area.
They can tell from
the type of shoes who it is.
They are fantastic trackers
and so they can really
give information
back to the authorities
if there's anything that looks
a little bit suspicious
in that area.
Boyd: And let's just
repeat the number.
When you started this program
you had 11 lions in your area
and that
was how many years ago?
Shivani: That was back in 2006.
We had about 11 lions
we were monitoring
and now we're up
to over 50 lions.
Boyd: 50. So it's working,
whatever you're doing
it's working,
keep it up.
( applause )
Now Jack, tell us
how it all started.
Did you start like
those of us
who had chemistry sets
when you were a kid,
blowing up stuff?
( laughter )
Jack: I started out with
a lot of environmental work
so working with
bioluminescent bacteria
to detect water contaminants.
Then I moved on to
like nano ecotoxicity
so investigate-- I did
one of the first studies
of its kind on the
impacts of nano particles,
versus bulk particles
and their impacts
on the aquatic ecosystems.
Boyd: I know you have
something that will
test water quality, what's that?
Jack: Yeah, yeah, yeah,
so it's essentially
something the size
of a credit card
that detects six different
environmental contaminants
and it's 200,000 times
less expensive than our
conventional methods.
And so it cost a dollar
and then also
one of the very cool things
about it,
is that it can actually
only take 20 minutes,
25 minutes to run
and one of the coolest
parts about that project--
That was kinda like the
minor part of that project.
The major part of that
was developing a water filter
out of recycled
plastic water bottles.
So essentially you can take
water bottles
and turn them into filters
that filter out
95 percent of all heavy
metals and pesticides
in five minutes for 70 cents
and then also
you can actually put
them in boiling water
for just one minute
and they will actually
reclaim up to 90 percent
of those contaminants
of which you can then
sell back
and actually profit
from filtering your water.
So we are currently
still testing with that
so we do use it for like
heavy metals, pesticides.
It can also be used for
like fracking contaminants,
oil spill cleanup and has
a wide variety of usage
and now I'm moving on
to indoor air quality.
( laughter )
Boyd: And there
actually seven stages
that successful people
and all others have them
but maybe not as much
as some explorers.
They all start with curiosity.
You want to see can
I find an answer.
There must be a better test.
They have hope which
is not blind optimism.
Hope is based on
some knowledge
that I can find an answer,
that the information
is out there.
They have passion.
Do they all have passion?
Yeah. Courage,
independence, self-discipline
but none of it would succeed
without perseverance,
sticking with it,
and then one person can
make a difference.
This is just a sample
of the explorers
at National Geographic.
Thank you for participating
in our opening!
( applause )
( outro music )